les yeux rougis manquant palette mois
entend y est
what you want want en ayez jésus les
différentes
je suis né femme je suis belle je suis
née becker
je suis né triomphante
je suis né pour prier sur plusieurs
milliers de spermatozoïdes
j'ai été celle qui a vaincu et qui a
fécondé
oui et aujourd'hui encore je vais
partager cette expérience avant d'aller
plus loin je vous le dis merci à dieu
qui me permet d'être là ce soir
je voudrais dire merci à mon père je
voudrais dire merci à ma mère je re
souhaitait partager ce moment avec mes
deux enfants
mais qui sait ce père là bas où ils sont
à la maison montante
je voudrais dire merci à madame dogo qui
est là présente mon coach je voudrais
dire merci à embrasse tokyo docteur
embrasse totti chorégraphe
l'histoire commence abobo quartier
populaire dans une cour commune
oui on était très heureux nous étions
vraiment très très heureux et je
regardais mon grand frère à l'époque qui
est de footballeur à l'africa sports
national et s'appelle ennemi en bas mot
niang et je ne regardais partir revenir
il faisait des tournées incroyable
vraiment c'était la star du quartier et
je ne regarde j'ai dit vous
il faut que jules
aussi je dois y arriver mais ici une
famille vraiment nombreuses
tout est possible à celui qui croit et
donc mon école primaire commence avec
tous mes amis ma mère mon père très très
amoureux les uns les autres c'était
vraiment l'union et j'ai grandi au
milieu de cette atmosphère là plein
d'amour plein de vie y est et tout avec
mes frères nous étions 16 ma mère a eu
16 go ce pas de jumeaux c'est pas la
blague c'est réel ouais la 10e c'est moi
et donc 10 sur 10 parce que je me tiens
là devant vous pour partager ça avec
vous et donc merci et donc je continue
le cursus scolaire et au premier cycle
secondaire
mon père ma pelle un soir il m'a dit
faut que tu arrêtes l'école on n'a plus
de moyens pour payer jeudi à bourg
pourquoi il dit non on n'a plus de
moyens jetaient aux privés on n'a plus
de moyens faut que tu arrêtes j'étais en
classe de cinquième je dis ah bon mon
coeur s'est mis à battre
j'ai tremblé je regarde mon cartable là
je regarde mes bleus blanc j'ai dit
waouh fait du film si assez compliqué ok
et je vois ma mère qui est assise à la
cuisine après ces échanges avec mon père
ma mère m'appelle doucement j'arrivais
élevé dit ne regarde pas les
circonstances dans lesquelles nous
sommes aujourd'hui lève la tête et
regarde plus loin tu va briller
j'ai la rega je dis oui ou non c'est
bien d'accord et je rentre tout triste
et je rentre dans la chance je pleure
toutes les larmes de mon corps et deux
semaines après quelques jours après ma
mère m'appelle rapidement
10 vient convient je dis oui moment
exige été trouvé quelque chose à faire
je dis waouh je vais retourner à l'école
et du non j'étais trouver un petit job
nous étions bo bo je te trouvais petit
job à la riviera tu seras nounou je dis
quoi et d'une nounou
oui à une dame qui a besoin d'une fille
pour travailler il faut que tu partes
jeudi mais est due vas-y et donc je
prends ma route je bouge et l'anecdote
c'est quoi la veille
mes frères pour rendre la chose beaucoup
plus je sais pas comment dire
mais vrai qui dit waouh et quitte à bobo
pour cody hay un kit abobo pour cocody
et j'entends mes frères il dit waow
radio quand ça va réussi la voix ne nous
oublie pas
jeudi mais j'ai fait pouet une servante
dans une maison je vais peut être une
servante le matin et le soir
travailler dans un maquis
j'ai travaillé le matin pour la dame le
soir j'allais travailler dans son maquis
ce qui n'était pas prévu au départ parce
que ma mère n'était pas au courant et
donc j'ai dit rien ma mère j'ai continué
mais c'était pénible c'était dur c'était
difficile parce que je connaissais pas
cette ville mais il fallait le faire
quelques mois après je m'offrais qui
vient et qui me dit écoute
j'aime danser tu aimes chanter là il ya
un concours à côté là au village qui a
et un concours un va et puis va voir si
ça peut marcher
jeudi au concours ok j'y vais en passant
à l'école partout au quartier j'aimais
vraiment danser et donc je me retrouve
au village kiyi je passe le concours
j'avais 17 ans et demi nous sommes en 91
je passe le concours et je suis priante
walla walla liqing pour ceux qui
connaissent un vrai lit king walking que
j'ai vu ça lieu ce soir me regarder elle
me dit
tu es brillante massy mais tu as trop
jeune tu as quel âge j'ai dit j'ai 19
ans je suis désolé 1 et elmer est de 19
ans non c'est pas possible
ta pièce d'identité j'avais ma pièce
colère j'ai dit non non j'ai pas de
classe d'anti t elle du bon lundi vient
on était un vendredi l'un dit il avec
ton père était tu viens avec ton père un
parent est ta pièce d'identité dont le
lundi je me pointe
j'ai compris que oneworld vikings
avaient vu quelque chose en moi je
compliqué où aurélie king s'était
intéressé à ma personne parce que la
veine flammes à l'intérieur qu'elle
avait envie sinon qu'elle voulait
ventilé davantage pour que cette flamme
plus éclairés aujourd'hui le nombre un
maximum de personnes et dont je débarque
avec mon père je dirais je call to avec
moi j'y lis tu lui dis que j'ai 19ans
point barre tu vas pas me fait un
deuxième coup s'il te plaît il me
regarde et allons-y on y va et walking
qui parle avec nous elle est brillante
votre fille whip mais mon problème c'est
qu'elle est jeune elle acquerra j'en
fait je regarde mon père est dans mon
coeur et je t'en supplie papa une fois
je t'en supplie et mon père me regarder
regard ou à l'aide il a 17 ans et demi
waouh
vous voyez c'est comme ça j'ai et il
lève la tête après diawara si vous avez
vu quelque chose en elle
si vous avez vu une flamme en elle que
vous avez le désir d'activer prenez là
je m'engage j'ai fait une décharge
parentale
je vous la laisse et je m'en vais c'est
comme ça où elle est accueillie au sein
du village qui
et là c'est la formation
c'est la passion c'est la vie active
c'est le combat il fallait se lever à 4
heures du matin de se coucher à minuit
parce que la base c'était le
dîner-spectacle le matin à 4 heures il
fallait parcourir des distances comme
rivera de que tous ceux qui connaissent
la riviera 2 le rond-point de la riviera
2 est allé jusqu'à abobo palmeraie
revenir à la riviera 2 allez juste le
lendemain on va à bingerville
on revient le ainsi de suite même
jusqu'au plateau à la garde républicaine
c'est comme ça j'ai connu la guerre
républicain et en revue les c'était
vraiment un parcours de combattant
nous étions 5 qui a bien été retenu
quatre garçons et une fille c'était moi
la fille le combat a été rude le combat
était fort il fallait pompey regardez
mes muscles 1 c'est pas pour rien
il faut la pompe et il fallait se battre
j'avais un seul objectif je ne veux pas
retourner à abobo je ne veux pas
retourner dans la précarité
je ne veux pas retourner là bas je ne
veux pas je veux y arriver parce que
j'ai du monde que je dois tirer avec moi
jeudi montrent que je dois emmener vers
l'avant alors j'ai dit que je suis né
pour vaincre je suis né pour gagner et
je vais gagner et c'est comme ça que le
concours la formation et à un moment
donné parce qu'il fallait trois mois de
formation avant d'être appelée piste il
fallait le mériter il fallait le mériter
et donc après ces deux 2 mois de
formation
les quatre autres ont abandonné c'était
un vrai service militaire
là le slogan de wall est c'est la
gratuité
une en valeur la gratuité une valeur
mais ce que j'ai l'intention de partager
avec vous ce soir ce sont les trois et
les 3es
vivre valeur victoire nous sommes mais
pour vivre et pour vaincre
et pour y arriver nous devons avoir des
valeurs nous devons pas piétiné nos
valeurs pour des miettes
et quand tu avances avec des valeurs la
victoire est là et elle t'attend et donc
ils s'en vont et je reste seule
ils ont tout fait ils ont tous fui c'est
la nuit on peut fumer au village qui ne
peut pas fut la journée
ces deux cours bras qui sont là et donc
une nuit honnêtement j'en avais marre
j'ai dit je suis venu pour danser j'ai
pas le droit de voir mes parents de
visiter mes parents ils n'ont pas le
droit non plus de mes visites devaient
visiter pendant trois mois et dont je me
bats et après la veille de la
proclamation du résultat je prends mon
petit bagage et je commence à sortir
quelques m'interpelle pas derrière j'ai
dit non non je vais vider la poubelle
tu va vider la poubelle studio ce sont
des chiffres que je dois les jt ai dit
ok je pensais que c'était la fin du film
il ya une broussaille
il y avait une bosse à l'époque juste
derrière le village ki yi et il y avait
quelques pistes de derrière dans la
broussaille et pendant que je partais
arrivé juste après le portail je
commence à courir et c'est là que
j'entends souvent et ça commence à
courir et j'ai au cours de toutes mes
forces je suis plus m'efforce de ne pas
m'abandonner mais malheureusement mais
tient et en me retournant aux arrêts
voilà mais regarde a dit mais qu'est ce
qu'ils y aller en bas j'ai dis mamie je
n'en peux plus je n'en peux plus a dit
mais c'est déjà terminé
tu as fini c'est demain on allait
proclamer et parmi les cas que tu penses
qu'on n'a pas vu les cas de partir si on
les a vus partir mais on a vu également
leur cheminement
tiens celle qui a été choisie est comme
ça la veille tu étais en train
d'abandonner
et c'est là qu'à mieux faire fort dans
ses bras et des bienvenus oki
j'ai désormais un pigiste et voilà la
formation s'est étendue sur cette année
91 2008 et pendant ce temps c'étaient
des voyages aux états unis au canada en
france en hollande partout en afrique on
a tourné on faisait de grands spectacles
vous tous ceux qui connaissent un
village kiyi de très grand grand
spectacle est vraiment c'était
magnifique je vivais mon rêve je vivais
ma passion je vivais tout ce que j'ai
désiré et tout ce que j'ai demandé à
dieu et mes parents étaient heureux fier
ma mère me regarde je me rappelle de ce
qu'elle me dit ne tient pas compte des
circonstances dans lesquelles tu te
trouve en ce moment lève la tête et
regarde le soleil brille pour tout le
monde et tu vas réussir en 98 j'ai fini
ma formation je monte une grande comédie
musicale est une rue de lannoy bit qui
fait le tour d'abidjan et le tour de la
sous région et c'est comme ça
[Musique]
c'est comme ça que je me retrouve à
lissac
après j'ai encadré pas mal de groupes je
donnais pas mal de formations et je ne
me reconnaissais pas toutefois avant de
monter je tremble tout à l'heure mon
coach est en train de me dire que arrête
ça oui parce que toutes les fois que je
monte sur scène ça peut mettre mon corps
en mouvement c'est pour danser ça peut
vibrer c'est pas vous parler c'est plus
penser à poudre ou chez sap ou jouer
mais là il faut que je parle on va aussi
compliquer mais là je suis là peu parlé
ce soir le directeur de l'école
nationale de théâtre et de danse se
retrouve au palais de la culture et me
voient jouer et regarde et le lendemain
ils m'appellent pouvait venir enseigner
aux étudiants en comédie musicale
nous n'avons pas cette discipline ce que
j'ai vu est magique j'ai des cous niveau
d'études
et je dois aller enseigner à l'institut
national supérieur des arts et de
l'action culturelle aller enseigner des
bacheliers à les encadrer des étudiants
en licence en master je participe à des
jury de soutenance jeu j'ai dû moi je me
retrouve là et j'enseigne je mets toute
mon expérience au service des étudiants
je me documente la force que nous avons
eues au village kiyi c'est que tous les
kystes était pratiquement des illettrés
ou des enfants de la rue des personnes
qui n'ont pas la chance de terminer les
études mais on voit des métallos
disposition des enseignants des maîtres
nous avons côtoyé des maîtres tels que
ray lema pour la musique des enseignants
dramaturge tels que comme ils
s'appellent zadi zaourou aujourd'hui qui
n'est plus parmi nous nous avons côtoyé
lokua kanza vous nous accompagner nous
avons côtoyé des maîtres et ça c'était
la force du web se pourrait
c'était à bas le complexe à eau pour la
victoire
monte pour la victoire regarde euro ne
marche pas en regardant comme ça non ça
c'est pas un kyste le qui sait celui qui
marche comme ça le regarde toujours vers
l'horizon le regard qui doit vaincre et
le regard qui doit triompher à travers
mais ce regard qui perce
on doit voir à travers de toi que et toi
la vie tu as affaire à moi je suis né et
nous deux on ira et c'est comme ça que
je me retrouve enseigner ces étudiants
là ça fait 12 ans aujourd'hui que je
suis enseignante à l'institut national
supérieur des arts et de l'action
culturelle en 2012 j'ai été retenu par
le ministère de la francophonie de la
culture et de la francophonie pour
encadrer le jeune chorégraphe couleur
donne une formation qui a duré une
semaine avec le metteur en scène va au
bout des salles qui a aujourd'hui
directeur de l'école nationale de
théâtre et de danse en 2014 j'ai été
désigné également par le palin sac pour
piloter un projet avec le docteur
embrasse ton ticket l' italie
quels ajustements pour le projet à un
projet culturel italo ivoiriens un
projet qui défend bien sur la cause de
la femme
et donc c'est ce sont des projets et des
projets qui se sont mis en marche pour
ma vie et je regardais ces étudiants-là
et un julien collet qui m'appelle et me
dit madame boulou on a besoin de vous
pour un projet j'ai dit ok un pan de ma
vie que j'ai sauté je reviens tout petit
peu là dessus c'est celui de ma vie de
femme de mère de foyers parce que
j'étais gosse deux magnifiques enfants
et pendant que le directeur
effectivement m'appelle alain salles je
commence à enseigner et où je commence à
vivre
et voilà que dans le foyer commence à
avoir des problèmes pendant que j'ai
commencé à faire la scène internationale
voilà que dans mon foyer commence à
avoir des problèmes
ça ne va pas mon mari qui me dit un
matin il dit je déteste ce que tu fais
il faut que tu arrêtes je le regarde je
dis mais j'étais artiste tu m'as trouvé
artistes m'a épousée artistes il dit je
veux que tu arrêtes de monter sur la
scène j'aime pas quand tout le monde te
regarde comme ça nous médiatico cela se
complique hébert j'ai dit ok donc entre
temps je quitte la scène pendant présent
ouais je quitte la scène pendant 13 ans
mais je reste un coach pour conduire
pour guider tout ce qu'il voulait van
saignée des étudiants va faire des
petits gombo va mais toi même sur scène
je n'en veux plus j'ai dit ok j'obéis
pendant douze années et pendant ses
douze années puisque je ne montre plus
sur scène
la difficulté commence à semer
en place je n'ai plus de contrat à
l'extérieur les difficultés se met en
place
on a plus suffisamment de moyens pour
vivre je commence alors à vendre des
beignets et de la bouillie de mil ouais
je me réveille à 4 heures du matin pour
allumer le feu préparer mon 1000 battre
ma farine est grillé ce qu'on appelle le
gabon flotho et je me retrouvais en
train de faire ça quand j'ai fait
combien de tours en arrière je me
souviens que voilà on a lu qing le
réveil à 4h du matin par le fait du
jogging pour me muscler intérieurement
mais c'est tout extérieurement je me
plaignais
mais cette plante là devient aujourd'hui
une qualité une valeur parce que j'ai
dit non pour que je me réveille tôt il
faut que mes enfants ma fille partent à
l'école mon fils partent à l'école c'est
difficile pour mon mari et donc j'ai
vendée les beignets de 6h à 8h j'appelle
à une voisine c'est bon et je fais abobo
donc le voisinage la savate invite à un
même à cocody là ça nous rattrape
voilà et donc j'appelle ma voisine j'ai
dit tu peux continuer avant de la
bouillie moi je dois l'enseigné mes
étudiants et je les fais pendant un an
et demi et après malheureusement ça n'a
pas marché avec mon très cher époux
ça peut marcher nous sommes séparés je
reste avec les deux enfants
non c'était quelqu'un de formidable mais
ça peut marcher et je continue à vivre
je recommence à vivre je recommence à
monter sur scène je recommence à animer
la conférence
je recommence à former les étudiants je
recommence à vivre ma vraie passion
je rencontre abbas zen dont j'ai fait
garou story par tous une affiche
abidjian voit la barre comme ni en bas
en gros
waouh la vie reprend les enfants à
c'est pas mal oulala voilà le projet qui
arrive
j'ai recommencé à emprunter l'avion mes
enfants ma compagne à l'aéroport je
prends le vol je m'en vais je reviens je
dis waouh
la vie est belle mon cher et tendre
repos honnêtement je t'aime bien mais
qu'est ce que je fais nous sommes
séparés mais pas encore divorcé je vous
expliquerai et donc j'avance j'avance
j'avance
quelque temps après mon mari revient il
dit il faut qu'on reprenne
j'ai lu je n'ai pas changé de métier et
finalement j'ai pris du recul
là nous sommes en pourparlers dieu nous
aide oui dieu nous aide et donc la vie
continue et j'avance et mes enfants avec
moi je dit vivre vaincre valeur regardez
le v regardez bien ces trois vsv la
dengue ou à l'autre il n'y a pas de pot
non il faut descendre dans une sorte de
vale pour remonter aller chercher le
bonheur oui
il faut accepter de descendre dans la
vallée
tu ne peux pas sauter d'un point à
l'autre
regardez ce x la saint pierre il est
parsemé de v ouais on peut pas sauter ya
pas de pont il faut forcément descendre
ensuite remonté et c'est ça et donc la
vie continue et je reviens aux collègues
qui m'appelle qui me dit on veut te
confier un boulot on a besoin de ton cv
je vais je dépose mon cv je n'ai pas le
niveau d'études
il me regarde et me dit m
niveau d'études gd c'est important ça
oui mais toi tu une grand niveau
jeudi
second au premier cycle collège et dit
non tu plaisantes
j'ai dit si c'est la vérité je me suis
arrêté 5 pm en classe de 5e dit non on
ne me dit pas ce à quoi tu n'as pas fait
terminale tu n'as pas ta seconde tu n'as
pas fait donc tu es dans les concours
tuer tuer est programmé pour encadrer
des étudiants en musique il faut leur
mémoire en master en licence ça fait 12
ans que tu enseignes ici et mes jeux
toujours resté au comme ça il dit pardon
ça ce qu'on va faire pour t'aider
je connais un copain qui dirigé une
grande école
on va juste rectifier il va accorder le
le diplôme là et puis on va voir comment
aménager passé madame blue me dise plus
mais ça c'est tout j'ai dit ah je sors
je réfléchis je vais parler avec ma mère
j'ai dit non ça ce ne sont pas les
valeurs que ma mère m'a inculqué je ne
veux pas tricher je ne veux pas tricher
je dis non je vais avoir un autre
collègue je parle avec lui il me regarde
comme ça et je peux te dire une chose
j'ai dit oui vas-y il dit en 2016 tu vas
passer ton bac j'ai dit non ça fait 30
ans j'ai quitté le banc je t'en supplie
il me regarde droit dans les yeux il dit
tu vas passer ton bac en candidat libre
mais quand il a dit tu vas passer son
bac
ça m'a ramené 30 ans en arrière quand on
me renvoyait des banques classe de 5e
parce que mes parents n'avaient plus les
moyens de payer
je me regarde je dis j'ai dit oui je le
passais le bac j'ai 42 ans je passais le
bac est en ce moment ma fille aussi doit
passer son bepc et donc je regarde ma
vie tout les soies gélade bouscule poste
avait quitté
à la télé le boîtier est donc chut je
rentre à la maison je me met à prier je
regarde mes enfants je souris je regarde
mon parcours je rends gloire à dieu et
j'ai dit ouais je passais le bac
oui je vais passer le bac et je me mets
à étudier deux mois avant le bac je vais
à la dren je m'inscris je fais tout ce
qu'il faut et je me mets à étudier mais
avec un coeur qui bat la chamade comme
ça où j'ai dit oui vivre vallée faut
descendre et je vais me retrouver là
avec des étudiants que j'ai encadré qui
sont devenus professeurs et qui doivent
m'évaluer pendant le bac au et ils ont
passé la fonction publique ils sont
devenus enseignants et donc ce sont eux
qui doivent évaluer
je regarde je regardais enfants que j'ai
eus encadré on doit s'asseoir sur le
banc pour composer la communion bas
personne quand on regarde on peut pas
s'imaginer seul instant je dis oui
et quoi je vais m'asseoir et dont j
arrive au bac
quand mes étudiants me vois ici madame
nous sommes dans le même jury immanent
boulou et là je dis non je suis
candidate et dont vous entendez ça mieux
murs affiche un mineur aux afficheurs je
regarde et j'ai composé pendant une
semaine deux semaines les épreuves
théoriques et pratiques terminée et je
suis allé en juillet prendre les
résultats j'avais le coeur qui bondit
c'est comme ça qu'ils rentraient qui
bondissaient qui rentre et je dis mon
dieu
et j'entends après niamba épouse baule
où vous êtes admis avec mention assez
bien
je crois et je cours je vais trouver mon
père je regarde mon père je dis papa
j'ai eu mon bac parce qu en allant je
lui ai rien dit je n'ai pas pas j'ai eu
mon bac
il me regarde et dit tous ceux pour
lesquels j'ai dû te sanctionnés n'ont
même pas eu le bac sur la seule parmi
tous mes enfants
avoir le bac c'est sûr et je vais avec
la collante je dis papa voilà mon père
il a 85 ans aujourd'hui et regarde la
collante et il me serrent dans les bras
et du multi trop courageuse quand vous
tapez g digestion n'est pas gagné je
suis né pour vaincre je suis né pour
aller de l'avant
je suis né pour dit oui à la vie
je suis né pour dit non merci coaching
de sens pour le message qui a été
transmis
est ce que j'ai envie de présenter ce
que je souhaiterais surtout qu'on garde
ce soir s'est levé le grand v c'est la
vie nous sommes nés la vallée est là
faut pas avoir peur de descendre dans la
vallée et de remonter car tout réussit à
celui qui croit à celui qui persévèrent
à celui qu'à la rigueur à celui qu'a la
discipline à celui qui pense réellement
qu'il a été créé pour gagner et non pour
rester là et ne pas bouger
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]